المباشره من مخيم بلاطه حيث العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه وهناك صور مباشره
التي نشاهدها الان تجمع لعدد من
الفلسطينيين في هذا الموقع
سيارات الاسعاف والطوارئ هناك لا ادري ما
يجري بالتحديد لكن كنا نشاهد قبل قليل
اثناء مداخله الياس والى الدحدوح
اصابات ولا ادري ما الذي جرى سيارات
الاسعاف والتجمعات هنا اذا سامر خويره
الصحفي من نابلس ما الذي جرى
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مخلف مشاهدين على
الاقل هناك
القناصه هم اكثر ناس في هذه العمليه
العسكريه اي شيء يتحرك
الصور مرعبه جدا هناك تفجير لراس احد
الشبان الرصافه اصابته في راسه بشكل مباشر
وهناك اصابه اخرى لشعب اصيب بعدد من
الرصاصات والجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مع
سيارات الاسعاف والمسافرين من الوصول
اليهم لكن مع انسحاب الجيش تمكن المواطنون
والسكان هناك من الوصول الى المكان وقاموا
بتغطيتهم
بشكل عام بشكل سريع الدماء تغطي كل مكان
اذا شهيدين على الاقل حتى الطواف كان
الطبيه الفلسطينيه في مخيم بلاطه عمليه
عسكريه كانت مباحثه مفاجئه استهدفت منزلا
حتى الان للعلم زميلتي لا يعلم لا يعلم
مصير امن كانوا محاصرين داخل المنزل يعني
لا لا مطلقا مطلقا الشباك استشهدوا على
بعديا من المكان ما قلت لك
العسكريه هي القناصه التي تطلق على كل ما
يتحرك
باب منزلها اطلاق الرصاص يكون بشكل جنوني
بشكل يستطيع ان يصل الى كل مكان المخيم
ضيق جدا ثقته متقاربه الناس بيوتها قريبه
جدا من بيوت بعضها البعض اي انسان يريد ان
يخرج من بيته يعني قد يكون عرضه لاطلاق في
الرصاص وقتله وهذا ما جرى على
الاقلاء الشابين هو كان يقف باب منزله
يتفرج فقط لا اكثر ولا اقل الرصاصه اصابته
براسه بشكل
نزف كميات كبيره جدا من الدماء هناك تهدد
كامل
الجمجمه لديه الشاب الاخر مصاب على الاقل
بثلاثه الى اربع رصاصات هذا يعني انه جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يطلق الرصاص بنيه
القتل فورا ما جرى انه المنزل المحاصر على
من كان هناك حديث عن تمكن على الاقل شخص
من الاشخاص الموجودين فيه من الهروب منه
وبالتالي الاحتلال يكون قد وقعت تعبير في
في حاله من الفشل